in 2011 a team of physicists reported a
startling discovery neutrinos traveled
faster than the speed of light by 60
billions of a second in their 730
kilometer trip from Geneva to a detector
in Italy
despite six months of double checking
the bizarre discovery refused to yield
but rather than celebrating a physics
revolution the researchers published a
cautious paper arguing for continued
research in an effort to explain the
observed anomaly in time the error was
tracked to a single incorrectly
connected fiber-optic cable this example
reminds us that real science is more
than static textbooks instead
researchers around the world are
continuously publishing their latest
discoveries with each paper adding to
the scientific conversation published
studies can motivate future research
inspire new products and inform
government policy so it's important that
we have confidence in the published
results if their conclusions are wrong
we risk time resources and even our
health in the pursuit of false leads
when findings are significant they are
frequently double-checked by other
researchers either by re analysing the
data or by redoing the entire experiment
for example it took repeated
investigation of the CERN data before
the timing error was tracked down
unfortunately there are currently
neither the resources nor professional
incentives to double-check the more than
1 million scientific papers published
annually even when papers are challenged
the results are not reassuring recent
studies that examined dozens of
published pharmaceutical papers managed
to replicate the results of less than 25
percent of them and similar results have
been found in other scientific
disciplines there are a variety of
sources for Ear reproducible results
errors could hide in their original
design execution or analysis of the data
unknown factors such as patients
undisclosed condition in a medical study
can produce results that are not
repeatable in new test subjects and
sometimes the second research group
can't reproduce the original results
simply because they don't know exactly
what the original group
however some problems might stem from
systematic decisions in how we do
science researchers the institutions
that employ them and the scientific
journals that publish findings are
expected to produce big results
frequently important papers can advance
careers generate media interest and
secure essential funding
so there's slim motivation for
researchers to challenge their own
exciting results in addition little
incentive exists to publish results
unsupportive of the expected hypothesis
that results in a deluge of agreement
between what was expected and what was
found in rare occasions this can even
lead to deliberate fabrication such as
in 2013 when a researcher spiked rabbit
blood with human blood to give false
evidence that is HIV vaccine was working
the publish or perish mindset can also
compromise academic journals traditional
peer-review processes which are safety
checks where experts examine submitted
papers for potential shortcomings the
current system which might involve only
one or two reviewers can be woefully
ineffective that was demonstrated in a
1998 study where eight weaknesses were
deliberately inserted into papers but
only around 25% were caught upon review
many scientists are working toward
improving rep reducibility in their
fields there's a push to make
researchers raw data experimental
procedures and analytical techniques
more openly available in order to ease
replication efforts the peer-review
process can also be strengthened to more
efficiently weed out weak papers prior
to publication and we could temper the
pressure to find big results by
publishing more papers that fail to
confirm the original hypothesis an event
that happens far more than current
scientific literature suggests science
always has and always will encounter
some false starts as part of the
collective acquisition of new knowledge
finding ways to improve the rep
reducibility of our results can help us
weed out those false starts more
effectively keeping us moving steadily
toward exciting new discoveries
you